>>> NOW, THE ANTIVAX MOVEMENT IS
PRIMARILY PORTRAYED AS A RED
STATE PHENOMENON.
BUT AS THE DAILY SHOW'S JORDAN
KLEPPER FOUND, VACCINE
HESITANCY, COVID MISINFORMATION
IS ALIVE AND WELL IN ONE OF THE
BLUEST REGIONS IN THE COUNTRY,
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DON'T YOU BENEFIT FROM A
SOCIETY THAT SUPPORTS THAT BY
GETTING VACCINATED?
>> YOU SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
FORCE THAT STUFF ON PEOPLE.
IT'S STEP ONE.
>> WHAT'S STEP TWO?
>> WHO KNOWS.
I'M NOT A CONSPIRACY THEORIST.
>> DIDN'T THEY HAVE STEP ONE
WITH POLIO?
>> THEY DIDN'T REALLY MANDATE
THAT.
PEOPLE WERE MORE WILLING TO TAKE
THESE SHOTS.
>> POLIO'S MANDATED FOR STUDENTS
GOING TO SCHOOL.
>> POLIO IS BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT
IT'S DONE.
>> DON'T WE KNOW WHAT COVID'S
DONE?
I MEAN, THERE ARE 750,000 PEOPLE
WHO HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA.
WHAT DO YOU RECOMMEND FOR BASIC
PUBLIC HEALTH?
>> DON'T WATCH THE NEWS BECAUSE
IT'S JUST BRAINWASHING YOU, WASH
HANDS AND NUTRITION.
THE FEAR IS LOWERING YOUR
FREQUENCY.
I ONLY EAT FISH AND ONLY CERTAIN
KIND OF FISH.
LIKE, FOR EXAMPLE, I DON'T EAT
TUNA.
I ACTUALLY FOUND THAT OUT WHEN I
WAS TRYING TO FEED TUNA TO MY
CAT AND SHE SHOOK HER HEAD AND
WALKED OFF.
>> DO YOU OFTEN TAKE MEDICAL
ADVICE FROM A CAT?
>> GENERAL FROM NATURE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
COVID VACCINE?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S A VACCINE.
I THINK IT'S SNAPPING THE DNA IN
HALF.
>> WHERE DID YOU HEAR THIS, A
SIAMESE CAT?
DO YOU RECOMMEND PEOPLE
MEDITATING, PEOPLE WORKING OUT
IN GROUPS, EATING HEALTHY?
>> DEFINITELY.
>> COVID VACCINE?
>> NO.
>> COFFEE ENEMA?
>> POSSIBLY.
>> MAYBE ON THE COFFEE ENEMA,
DEFINITE HARD NO ON THE COVID
VACCINE.
>> NO.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS THE ONE AND
ONLY JORDAN KLEPPER, CONTRIBUTOR
FOR "THE DAILY SHOW," WHICH AIRS
11:00 P.M. ON COMEDY CENTRAL.
I'M INTERESTED, WHAT WAS AT
EXPERIENCE FOR YOU TRYING TO
EXPOSE THE ANTIVAX MOVEMENT KIND
OF ON THE LEFT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA?
>> WELL, IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
FIGURE OUT A REASON TO GET OUT
TO LOS ANGELES AND LOOK FOR NEW
WORK.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT CHALLENGE.
BUT WE HAD ACTUALLY MYSELF AND A
PRODUCER, WE HAD BEEN OUT TO LOS
ANGELES A FEW WEEKS PRIOR, AND
SORT OF THE UNSAID COMMENTS
WHEREVER WE WENT WERE ABOUT THIS
ANTIVACCINE MOVEMENT WITHIN THE
WELLNESS COMMUNITY.
SO FOR US THIS IS A STORY WE
DON'T HEAR MUCH ABOUT.
SO OFTEN YOU HEAR THIS RETICENT
TO INDULGE IN A VACCINE IS ONLY
ON THE RIGHT.
SO WE SAID IT'S ABOUT TIME FOR
US TO GET IN A PLANE, GO TO
SUNNY, SUNNY CALIFORNIA, PACK
THE SPF 700 AND TALK TO FOLKS
AND SEE IF THE WELLNESS
COMMUNITY HAS ANYTHING IN COMMON
WITH THE MAGA CROWD.
>> YOU SPOKE TO A JOURNALIST
WHO'S BEEN STUDYING THE
ANTIVACCINE MOVEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA AND HOW IT'S BEEN
DRIVEN BY THESE PEOPLE IN THE
WELLNESS, AND I PUT UNDER QUOTES
THERE, WELLNESS INDUSTRY.
AND HERE'S WHAT HE TOLD YOU.
>> YOU HAVE MEDITATIONS THAT ARE
SOLD THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO WARD
OFF COVID.
YOU ALSO HAVE DIFFERENT
BREATHING TECHNIQUES.
SOME PRACTITIONERS INCLUDING
HERE IN LOS ANGELES TEACH
BREATHING WORKSHOPS BECAUSE
COVID IS A RESPIRATORY ILLNESS.
SO THEIR BELIEF IS IF YOU'RE
BREATHING PROPERLY IT WON'T
AFFECT YOU.
>> THAT'S A CLASS YOU CAN PAY
FOR HERE?
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY A CLASS
YOU CAN PAY FOR.
>> HOW MANY SMOOTHIES DOES ONE
HAVE TO INGEST TO GET TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY CAN COMPLETELY
DISREGARD THE HEALTH OF THE
COMMUNITY THEY LIVE IN?
>> IN LOS ANGELES, ONE BECAUSE
THEY'RE USUALLY $25.
>> SO WAS THAT THE THEME HERE,
DO A BUNCH OF YOGA WHEN IT COMES
TO THE PANDEMIC THAT'S KILLED
750,000 PEOPLE?
>> I THINK YOGA AND BONE BROTH
SMOOTHIE ENEMAS AND YOU'VE GOT
YOURSELF A PACKAGE THAT'S GOING
TO KEEP YOU PRETTY HEALTHY FOR A
WHILE.
WHAT I STARTED TO SEE IS THIS
WELLNESS COMMUNITY, AND THERE
ARE FOLKS WHO ARE FOCUSED ON
HEALTH AND HELPING ONE ANOTHER,
BUT JUST LIKE ANY KIND OF
COMMUNITY, THERE ARE PEOPLE
LOOKING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT
AND MAKE MONEY OFF PEOPLE WHO
NEED HELP AND WANT TO CHANGE
THEIR LIVES.
MUCH LIKE WHAT I'VE SEEN ON THE
OTHER SIDE, YOU HAVE FOLKS WHO
HAVE EGO AND THEY THINK THEY
KNOW MORE THAN SCIENTISTS.
THEY HAVE CULTISH FIGURES AND A
SOCIAL MEDIA BUBBLE.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE A VERY SIMILAR
SITUATION, TO SOME DEGREE.
AND THAT EXTENDS TO SOMETHING
WE'VE COVERED A LOT HERE, WHICH
IS REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
YOU'RE THINKING MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE OR LAUREN BOEBERT WHO
HAVE COMPARED COVID MANDATES TO
NAZI GERMANY.
YOU ALSO RAN INTO THAT ON YOUR
TRIP.
>> I THINK WHAT'S INTERESTING
ESPECIALLY COMING FROM GERMANY,
I THINK HISTORY'S REPEATING
ITSELF RIGHT NOW.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SAYING?
>> THAT THE VACCINE MANDATES AND
EVERYTHING, IT'S TURNING INTO A
POLICE STATE.
>> AND YOU'RE EQUATING IT TO
WORLD WAR II-ERA GERMANY?
>> YES, WHERE ARE YOUR PAPERS,
WHERE ARE YOUR PAPERS?
>> BUT JEWISH PEOPLE ARE FLEEING
POLAND BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET
INTO GYMS?
>> THAT'S NOT FUNNY.
YOU JUST DIDN'T GET THE POINT.
SORRY.
I'M GOOD.
BYE.
>> IT WAS REALLY TRAGIC THAT
INTERVIEW ENDED RIGHT THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING IN THAT
MOMENT WHEN YOU'RE GETTING THAT
ON CAMERA?
>> WELL, I'M THINKING THAT
AMERICANS LACK CREATIVITY.
IT SEEMS AS IF WE CAN ONLY GO TO
ONE GIANT EVENT FOR ANY
REFERENCE POINT.
I THINK WE ALSO LACK ANY KIND OF
HISTORICAL CONTEXT.
AND, SADLY, I'M NOT THAT
SURPRISED.
SHE'S NOT THE ONLY PERSON WHO
REFERENCED WORLD WAR II.
I'VE BEEN TO ANTIVAX MANDATES IN
NEW YORK CITY, LOS ANGELES.
MULTIPLE PEOPLE BROUGHT THAT UP.
I THINK WE OFTEN SEE OUR LIVES
AS ONE GIANT TRAGEDY.
AND WITH LACK OF IMAGINATION, WE
GO TO THE LARGEST THING WE CAN
GRAB A HOLD OF.
IN MOST PEOPLE'S CASE, THAT IS
WORLD WAR II.
AND THEY LACK AN UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT THOSE PEOPLE WENT
THROUGH.
THEY SEE THEMSELVES AS GOING
THROUGH THE GREATEST TRAGEDY
IMAGINABLE.
AND FOR THAT WOMAN THAT TRAGEDY
INVOLVED GETTING A SHOT TO TRY
TO HELP HER COMMUNITY.
SO, ALTHOUGH YOU'LL HEAR
SOMETIMES AT WELLNESS COMMUNITY
HEAR THE WORLD OR YOU'LL HEAR
EVEN IN THE FAR RIGHT COMMUNITY
WE THE PEOPLE, YOU OFTEN SEE IN
ORDER TO TAKE CARE OF ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE YOU MIGHT HAVE TO
MAKE SOME SORT OF SELF-SACRIFICE
FOR THE BETTERMENT OF ALL.
BUT THAT OFTEN SEEMS LIKE A STEP
TOO MUCH.
SO THEY STICK WITH WORLD WAR II
COMPARISONS.
>> YEAH.
THE EASY AND COMPLETELY
NONLINEAR COMPARISONS.
JORDAN KLEPPER, I ALWAYS LAU